we've been together for just over a year
now right mm-hmm we've been together for
about two years
yeah you have to nap years yeah we are
not a couple
we are just friends what different I
would describe it as very comfortable in
a good way
not in a bad way we work out all yeah is
this a fitness gear no no we have our
ups and we have our very low down but
like at the end of it all we're still
here
obviously he is cute and superficial
well if that's the first thing we're
going off of I want to do that you were
super cute at first at first I feel like
the initial attraction was definitely
like a very like physical attraction
we both neutrally found each other yes
doesn't like to admit that he started it
she did you got not gonna defend my show
he just doesn't want the world I care I
can't say I care
[Music]
I'm dr. Wendy Walsh and I'm a partner in
instant chemistry comm where we look at
couples genetic predisposition to get
attracted and stay attracted across the
lifespan when we look at compatibility
we look at potential for hot passionate
sex that will last we look at
personalities that match and we look at
psychology that supports each other so
you guys scored 75% compatibility in
serotonin which is actually about
average she's passionate and strong
govern yeah stubborn yes so you're able
to tolerate that and be more
level-headed and practical if that's
those moments you actually only have 50%
compatibility here because you're both
able to elicit a strong emotional
response under stress and if that
happened to both of you at the same time
it makes it harder to you know get
through life's bumps in a relationship
not great you have a 75% compatibility
which is pretty high how does it feel to
you guys I think it makes all the sense
in the world they go ahead now I think
it makes all I've been saying this for
three years that like I see cuz I'm
level-headed I'm logical all the time
and Asia is like never gonna hear you
are you gonna tell me that I'm like
you're acting very logical right now
they show you're acting a little your
serotonin levels are not where they
should be
you guys came out so high on intimacy
intimacy means that you're quite
comfortable sharing emotional intimacy
together intimacy fascinating I'll even
do pretty good so far yes this actually
but you both really value openness and
closeness as far as emotional intimacy
is concerned check us out yeah you guys
scored very high on intimacy both of you
what yes I swear to you I try to be nice
to him and there are days I'm like ooh
I'm gonna be nice to you today and then
he'll just be a butthole to me because
he doesn't believe that I'm being honest
and then we get back in this circle but
I have tried she's being fake and and
when have you ever known anything about
me to be frank the one that most couples
are really excited to hear about is the
HLA gene they are the thing that makes
you have hot passionate sex and there is
some research to show that if you are
highly compatible in this area that you
will have longer passionate sex across
the lifespan so how did you guys score
on that important HLA gene 65% so not
low littlelow average so that's saying
we don't have hot sex it's saying it's
bad it's saying that that part of the
relationship is less important is less
important you guys came out
seventy-three percent compatible now the
average couple actually is only a little
higher than that like 74 75 percent so I
would call you within the average range
I'm straight-up average in bed you ready
yes the highest score I've ever slept up
what talking about you're 90 percent 90
percent yeah so overall your
compatibility was a little bit low it
was 68 percent out of the three you guys
actually have the lowest biological
compatibility great you might have the
lowest score on biology but you have the
highest score on neuro compatibility
overall you
at 70% which is a really strong high
average it is yes oh it doesn't all your
need that's all you need what you guys
have is a good solid foundation on all
levels you guys were the highest overall
oh wow I've never seen a 90 percent
better than a passion gene it's almost
perfect perfect sex forever that's
that's oh man that is wild honestly at
the end of the day I feel like this is a
test and the true test is just Annie and
me in our daily life choosing to love
each other and nothing is gonna change
that for me
I think this fund actually kind of lets
me know there's a little bit more
science behind like the kismet of
relationships I just feel weird I need
to go and like decompress I think that's
what it is any alike like sit down and
look at a ceiling for over for a bit and
let these numbers like soak in there's
one other little bit of data that we
looked at do you know who is the most
likely to have the healthiest happiest
most passionate and most exciting
relationship out of all six of you I
feel weird saying oh yeah me and Jordan
totally do well together oh my god yeah
but your unconscious knows cuz you just
said it you enjoyed oh man really strong
let's go ahead we do if I apologize wow
really yeah you had the highest
compatibility out of all six you and
Jordan dang I can see that
[Music]